so once it became clear that the El Paso
shooter was a right-winger radicalized
by many of the same ideas that have been
fomented by this administration leaving
a right-wing manifesto Republicans had
to rally around something else some
other talking point and the talking
point they chose basically was video
games we've got to do something about
video games with some vague mentions of
social media in the background for
credibility's sake I guess and we're
gonna get into some of these examples
now just a reminder this video is going
to be demonetised on youtube almost all
of today's show will be demonetised on
youtube because it's a show about
shootings terrorism radicalization
important stuff i've spoke to some other
shows some people are choosing not to
cover this in order to retain
monetization we've got to cover this
stuff okay so I'm asking you leave us a
tip today become a member at join
pakman.com to help out with the fact
that today's show is going to be a
freebie in the sense of a no revenue
show so they bring out this tired trope
of video games cause people to become
radicalized and violent and go out and
act out all of that violence in the real
world here's just one short example from
Fox News all right what about video
games so many of these school shooters
and others have been sort of raised on a
diet of violent video games now this has
been studied video games may may cause
already violent people or people
predisposed to violence to go out into
the world in some cases and commit a
real-world act of violence that they've
already been predisposed to and
potentially have even been thinking
about but video games by and large are
not causing violence in otherwise
nonviolent people they will not
indoctrinate perfectly reasonable people
into the anti-immigrant xenophobic white
nationalist delusions of the el paso
shooter and this came up again when
Texas lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
went on Fox News take a look at this and
I and I look at this evil act and let's
condemn it for what it is evil evil and
I and I say how long are we gonna let
for example and ignore at the federal
level particularly where they can do
something about
the video game industry you know in this
manifesto that we believe is from the
shooter this manifesto he talks about
living out his Super Soldier fantasy on
Call of Duty another republican Kevin
McCarthy also on the video game talking
point bandwagon and sometimes they try
to temper it a little bit by talking
about social media which does present a
whole slate of issues societally but
that really shouldn't be mixed in with
this video game talking point take a
look but what are your thoughts on that
in terms of understanding that words
matter and that when we're talking to
each other on social media or looking at
video games where they're using you know
videos of characters with these weapons
is there a conversation to be had about
that about the tone that that this
country is using it's become commonplace
to say whatever you want to anybody on
social media I think we should and you
want to see from these individuals what
they wrote in others but I mean this may
be a place that we could find this ahead
of time there may be a place of what
what's being written can be changed
could be an indication that individual
needs help and others that we can stop
but the idea of these video games to
dehumanize individuals to have a game of
shooting individuals and others I've
always felt that is a problem for future
generations and others we've watched
from studies it's shown before of what
it does to individuals when you look at
these photos of how it took place you
can see the actions within video games
and others but what I'd like to do is
make sure just get all the facts so we
don't have to pretend that violence in
movies and video games has zero no
effect on anyone culturally in any way
but the El Paso shooter is a guy
radicalized around specific radical
right-wing ideologies people who play
video games and aren't radicalized by
the stuff that Trump has been spewing
aren't going to go out and commit
violence like this I did a twitch stream
last night by the way you should be
following me there twitch.tv slash David
Pakman and people asked me do I play
video games and I said
I don't play very many video games but
the one that I've been playing since I
was quite young are the different
iterations of grand theft auto one of
the most violent games that is out there
and there's absolutely no connection
whatsoever between the cartoonish
violence in the game and anything that
I've ever even considered doing in the
real world and importantly you know
other countries have video games look at
Japan and look at the fact that there
are basically no shootings in Japan
every country has racist people every
country has atheists for those who want
to blame the fact that you know God is
no longer in school every country has
mental illness other countries don't
have the problems that we have even
though they have lots of these other
ancillary characteristics and there are
also more general crime statistics to
consider remember that video game
playing in the United States has gone up
for decades violence in total has also
been going down for decades the general
trend is video games up violence downs
so we have to look at the nitty gritty
and the particulars of the types of
shootings that were actually having and
again just as importantly by proportion
there is just as much video gaming in
other countries and those countries
don't have our mass shooting problems
this same guy Dan Patrick the Texas
lieutenant governor went on another Fox
News show and said we've got to really
be careful about Antipa and tifa's got
to stay away as if that has anything to
do whatsoever with this shooting and
again a law enforcement bit of the basic
thing it's just did an amazing thing as
your guest I just heard a little bit of
your previous guests talking about the
crime scene and you know one there's one
or two people shot you can imagine the
size of this crime scene and this would
be an investigation that will take some
time you know this you know I was I was
looking at a story recently I just saw
in the last couple of days where antifa
is posting you know they want to come
down Paso and do a tenth day siege clear
message banty for Stan of El Paso Stan
of Texas basically but we don't need
them coming in on September 1st we
didn't need them to begin with before
this happened but I would I would say to
an Tifa scratch Texas off your map and
don't come in it is not the time and
place for them to come at any time
but particularly in the aftermath of
what's just happening in El Paso so
antiva message for lieutenant governor
now you know I've never defended an tyfa
or any political violence but the idea
of saying given that a guy just math
shot and killed 20 people and injured
many more on the basis of this
right-wing anti-immigrant xenophobic
white nationalist ideology now I should
also mention we don't need an Tifa here
as if there's some kind of equivalency
between the two groups and of course in
the background of every single one of
these clips what's the elephant in the
room it's never guns and that's likely
the motivation for the fact that so many
Republicans are jumping on the video
game talking point it's never guns and
that we shouldn't talk about but it's
also never right wing radicalization
either that also not coming up it's
video games and we've got to be careful
about antiva and next we literally have
the juxtaposition of interrupting
right-wing radicalization to report on a
right-wing shooting and of course never
mentioning that the shooter actually
left a right-wing manifesto let's talk
about that next do you stand for the
environment and for women's rights
there's a phone company that stands with
you and it's credo mobile credo is the
only phone company in America that
supports the same cause as you do causes
like fighting to stop climate change to
protect reproductive freedom and
immigrant rights credo donates a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars every month
to groups like Rainforest Action Network
Planned Parenthood the ACLU and many
more
while other phone companies are spending
millions of dollars to push mega-mergers
through and funding right-wing
politicians you make choices every day
about where you spend your money I've
talked about voting with your dollars
make your mobile phone one of those
choices
switch to credo mobile now and as a
reward you'll get 12 pints of Ben and
Jerry's ice cream that's a pint a month
for 12 months how about some of that
Cherry Garcia right you'll also get
coverage on the nation's largest most
reliable network you'll get low rates
you'll get a complete selection of smart
phones including the latest models from
top brands make the switch go to credo
dot-com slash Pakman or enter the offer
code
at checkout that's CRE do.com slash
Pakman